the standout game of the upcoming match  day is live session versus often I say  wow she's a year the nah I'm of nine  eight ish Hoffenheim wow are you serious  the same situation as eight years ago at  that time Hoffman we're at the leipzig  of today billionaire hope is half limes  mateschitz and he was and is the  mastermind those stories of fun naked he  was my coach at fault we stood guard  meticulous his slaves was a football but  [ __ ] I'm and Leipzig have brought a  little excitement to the league little  suspense hoffenheim are the only Club in  Europe's top leagues who are unbeaten  this season and they will not lose  Atlantic it will be a juicy draw maybe a  22 what do you think drop me a line